When you were making $5 a night,
literally $5 thousand night as a comedian.
I was so much happier than when I had a day job.
Oh yeah.
Making real money.
Once the,
I remember the feeling of being able to make a living with just stand up.
Yeah.
Like what?
Like holy cow and not a good living.
Just getting by.
In my beginning it was super shaky.
Yes,
super shaky.
Right?
Like I started making money.
I was making like a little bit of money in Boston,
but I always had day jobs when I moved to New York and then Jeff started
managing me.
Then I started making money,
like he get me booked in places and I was doing,
I was working pretty much every weekend.
Who Is Jeff?
Jeff Sussman.
Sussman.
Longtime manager started managing me when I was an open miker.
Oh,
nice.
Yeah.
We've been together forever.
Well,
he's the best.
He's still with them.
Yep.
Wow.
That's amazing.
Best.
He's the best.
I love the guy.
That's great.
He's an awesome person too,
and just brilliant at his job.
Super Low key.
Doesn't give a fuck about Hollywood just so that's great.
But you know,
he's,
he understands it right to do right.
He doesn't care.
He's like to do what makes you happy once he just wants you to be happy.
It's awesome.
So he picked you up when you're doing open mikes too.
Dude,
I'll just scrub it wasn't even supposed to go on stage that night.
Really?
He came into town.
He had managed some other comedians.
I remember Bob Nelson.
No,
Bob Nelson.
Jeffy Jeff football guy.
Yeah.
You may have that.
Oh my God.
He can manage him.
Oh really?
Yeah,
and he produced his HBO special.
Wow.
And um,
they were partying ways and uh,
they were parting ways and Jeff was like,
well,
maybe I've seen everybody that I've seen in New York,
maybe I'll take a trip to Boston.
So he took a trip to Boston and just fucking dumb luck when I was driving limos,
I wrote a joke that day.
I had this joke and I called up my friend Oliver,
who was the manager at the club and I said,
hey man,
can I come in and do like five minutes cause I have this joke,
I want to try out.
I said,
sure,
come on in.
And he liked me.
So he hooked me up.
And uh,
I went on stage and I didn't even know Sussman who was in the room when,
cause I didn't know he was in the room.
I didn't give a fuck.
I was super loose.
You knew who he was at that point?
No,
I didn't know who he didn't know.
So it just didn't,
it wouldn't,
but I knew that there was a manager from New York,
right.
That handled Bob Nelson.
I'd be like,
Holy Shit,
I probably freak out and sure I'd choke
shop,
act as shaky as fuck back then anyway,
you know,
I'm only like,
of course we wouldn't have three years in a colony or something like that.
I was terrible happened anything did often.
It was really interesting.
Like he took me to New York to,
um,
he saw me there and then he took me into New York to try out.
He wanted to see me perform in some other clubs.
So he said,
we,
are you willing to come down in New York?
So I said,
sure.
Yeah.
I've always wanted to,
I was so nervous about performing in New York.
Of course.
I thought New York City was different.
There was like more nervous than when he came to see me the second time in
Boston.
I was more nervous to perform in New York.
I was like,
I can't believe I was one of at catch a rising star,
which doesn't exist anymore.
Just legends.
Forget it.
Your head.
Yeah.
That's a big thing.
It's on because you don't know it yet.
Yeah.
Well,
it was like the New York comics were always like the smart ones.
Yeah.
That was the thought process.
They insert your thought process in Boston.
The audiences are smarter.
They're not going to buy your bullshit smarter over there.
Yeah.
No,
you're not funny.
You're going to know.
They're gonna know.
And uh,
it's really funny.
He's like Sussman.
We were talking about like clean comedy versus dirty comedy and there was no
really real decision like you know like,
because back then people would like decide to be clean.
It wasn't like you're a clean comic because that's how you think.
It's like,
well,
if you want to get more work,
the smart moves through clean as a business decision,
as a business decision should dress nice and act clean.
Took me to this place called,
we went to a bunch of places,
did eat side comedy club,
which is a cool comedy club that used to be in long island.
Then he took me to this place called fast eddies and Huntington and it was a,
it was a local bar that had a comedy night.
Wow.
We went upstairs and it was so,
the crowd was so fucking rowdy and so drunk and there was a dude on stage.
His name was George Gallows hilarious dude who was doing a reverse shit with a
banana.
It's like as you're waiting to go on,
so you had a banana that he was like,
he was somehow or another slurping,
like there was a reverse shit and he's doing this in front of,
you know,
these people are hammered.
It's like a Wednesday night or some shit,
right?
And sustenance says he grabs her.
By the time you don't have to perform here,
we're going to,
we're going to get out of it.
And I said,
no fucking way.
I go,
listen man,
I'm going to be to my people.
I go,
just trust me.
Let me go out my paper.
I'm like,
this is what I do,
man.
All the gigs that I got in bosses were all bargains.
Course handle them.